in my generation shingo katayama used to
warm up with his five wood left-handed
is that back in the 50s or
late late 50s
if you call Charles Barkley a fat ass
they will not give you the drink that
you requested on the golf course Justin
Thomas such a great he's such a great
kid you know we have a little robbery
because I went to Auburn University and
he went to Alabama University and
they're competitors but the value uh
Auburn it's the university
but he went to Alabama University
I don't know but they're the they've got
the honor because of JT's cut on the
last so
um
they're the guinea pigs we get to learn
from their shots so we'll see you
rebuttal there Jordan no I I think
you okay man I'm all right all right
care if I stand right here or you want
me to move uh you're good you know it
doesn't bother me I know that the little
things bother you Jordan yeah that's
fair I teed that one up shoot
putter mark
huh it's a Potter mark
it is
best thing about sports man is trash
talk in the locker room is the greatest
thing that's the only thing I miss
some kind of way to plug the sponsors
Jason I mean Jordan Jordan got that
sponsor is that good or bad you will not
believe your good fortune good ah good
things happen to good people boys
Chuck's looking at that Moon like it's
an oreo
it is dinner time okay JT
I forgot to tell you guys tiger gets a
stroke here so
oh there we go I'm glad I didn't say it
yeah no kidding but I didn't say that
just please don't piss him off guys
Rory it's good yeah pick it up
you guys did not just do that
I could feel it I knew you guys were up
to someone
oh my goodness that's Karma okay no we
deserve that bad Juju but I I don't
think they were not making four I I
don't think anybody anybody in the booth
want to bet against tiger from five feet
there no way maybe you have to ask
Jordan he's a little more used to being
in these positions hey Rory you got a
light in the way this is where you use
the rules to your advantage
see these are the things I'm just not
experienced though
tiger
lights
no he he got become my idea
moving the card on them and having not
having a good lie but he took my key oh
that's funny he did and he didn't take
this away though oh yes
time honored tradition I got you hold on
a second let me get your key
just two College dropouts out here
you know JT I don't even know why I like
you man
[Laughter]
you're such a good dude and a great
player but you went to Alabama
University and it just drives me crazy
that you're successful
chuck if you say Alabama University one
more time
I mean I know you have to Auburn you may
not be the brightest but you know it's
University of Alabama well I know that
but every time I see it I piss somebody
off in Tuscaloosa well it's a great
building well it pissed me off right in
front of you so it worked hey Chuck
Chuck owes me a dinner he lost a couple
years ago on on an iron ball bet and he
still hadn't paid I do owe you money as
soon as I found an Applebee's down here
we're going back ajt I'm not gonna lie
I'm impressed with the Cavs man I I've
never seen you wear shorts before but
I'm saying man he got some nice calves
thanks Chuck I appreciate that I'd
prefer if you didn't talk about me like
that again don't mind it in all of us
combined he's paying all the overdue
bills I don't know Chuck I saw that
TNT's contract you just had pretty
recent well that only depends if we keep
the NBA after three years
a winner
come on like a little bit
uh second place isn't bad guys
the joy out of getting this is does not
match the joy of standing here with
tiger just being so upset that he has to
Stand Here For This